stravaccato sulla sedia scillato come
pochi che gioca potrà mai essere ma
proprio della indigo vice di riprovare
sempre isaac ma per il fatto che
comunque il rollo ecco il fatto delle
non posso trovare oggetti nuovi più easy
quindi o usare proprio sempre aisa
questo periodo almeno finché siamo
all'inizio per scoprire un po di 99 va
bene ma mano
regia è già una stanza in credito o per
iniziato già stato impossibile vabbè che
culo
[Musica]
da rischiata e lo rischiata almeno
andiamo subito sulla 3g è
la madonna quanta roba trovato
fantastico mag no ce l'ha sacri file
madonna
no fermi pazzesco c'è praticamente
questi ti non ti fanno danno ma ti
tolgono le labbra energia
all'oggetto pazzesco che nemico pazzesco
che alle volte
c'è adesso in questo caso è ottimo però
alle volte può essere bastarda come cosa
perché alle volte la carica dell'oggetto
più importante della tua stessa vita
e non sto scherzando c'è veramente
incredibile adesso è andata ancora bene
va bene with all aja porca vacca e vabbè
se colpiscono intanto qualcosa mi fa
mela me li fa diventare amici non ho
capito sta roba
ma perché perché mi diventa amica
si ceylon blacks che fa sta roba
non so perché strano
cosa mi dà bello lo uso psp shop sfida
va benissimo non avrei mollato niente
allora andiamo lì qua ragazzi sempre le
parti nuove sempre le parti nuove perché
sono molto più difficili però almeno
vedo io vedo le cose nuove non so che
teoricamente dovrei vincere però mi
interessa vedere le cose noi quindi per
adesso che altro solo qua devo
ricordarmi però che mi serve sempre una
chiave in più perché per entrare mi
serve una chiave però poi mi serve anche
per per la 3 giu in questo caso adesso
non c'ero porco demonio li vediamo di
crohn a chiave eccola per culo
del iv
allora ragazzi del iv è uno degli
oggetti più rari del gioco è
potenzialmente un oggetto pazzesco
perché fa questo guardate del iv
denominata si chiama junior ed elite
vedrete fa questo tu stai fermo e
diventi così quando sei così 6 immortale
però non puoi fare niente non puoi
attaccare s'attacchi ti toglie
l'immortalità dell'attrice cosa serve se
non puoi attaccare come luci nemici se
tu hai un minion che ti fa danno ai
nemici
hai vinto perché presidente fa tutto lui
lasci che faccia tutto lui quindi la del
drift leaf come grassi dice è ottima
non so se nei secchi c'è qualcosa nel
dubbio le metto qui
c'è un nemico ottimo diamo al boss
direttamente ragazzi un'ottica che c'è
un nemico o cielo fosse chi mano pezzo
di culo prendi se kimi rilancia sto
pezzente maledetto che io presi la
chiave me la tengo perché se non riesco
ad aprire la porta dopo ok a wall mount
questo qua è difficilissimo lo trovate
l'altra volta mi è andata bene solo
perché avevo la fiamma blake baggett fa
un danno ce la fanno più di lo stesso
danno ma nel senso edifici da schivare
porca [ __ ] è uno di quei di quelle
sanguisughe è formato extralarge e
orribile
yes no questa è la merda
questo è buono decisamente meglio di
essa c'è un sacco di tears sparo
velocissimo vi servono due bombe per
entrare nella stanza quella di fianco
rega non so se entra c o meno
ok poi c'è l'altra bomba ma si dà il
piano va bene mi aumentato ed years che
adesso sono praticamente al massimo
se non al massimo ma quasi
v series paper
film fight non solo non solo la faccia
sicuramente prodotto uno i boss
ciao
andiamo nelle miniere ragazzi ormai le
miniere sono a casa nostra qua
cioè è vietato minecraft sempre più
difficile tra l'altro prova altro che
schifo quanti ufficio
poi stoner aveva intanto di vento tipo
invisibile non capisco che campioni
let's be
nice per un'altra porta i pochi rossi
questi cosa normale voglia a devo farli
fuori anche quando muoiono e sono ok
pochi rossi sempre a far fuori i ragazzi
che ti fregano come niente non ho più
visto le segrete ma chissene maglia che
è male che è successo a sono bombe
volanti ottimo buono a sapersi
io dovrei avventarmi il danno perchè
così fanno vi danno anche i ragni e
dovrei avere un altro mineo
assolutamente sì in cuore grazie a dio
meno male al bacino a tinte ed ho visto
il buon rock nice smo rock i ragazzi
tifando al po più lento ma attivamente
al danno non male quindi se aumenta un
po la velocità siamo a cavallo
oa metà almeno il danno adesso che è
aumentato mini sfrutto meglio i ragnetti
allora qua dentro
no che schifo allora qua devo prendere
st bombe tirargli la sopra
ok
va bene ma quindi posso anche sfruttarla
per lanciarla sul muro si che poi non
c'è niente proverebbe
che figata sta cosa comunque delle bombe
rosse ragazzi va bene regoliamo vediamo
cosa c'è il dente non è male ogni tanto
mi spara un dea no
siamo nel nostro foto una cazzata ho
detto niente gretzky dehon gretzky dehon
non so chi sia
che cacchio è un
ragazzi
non ha una vita
non ha una vita lega cosa vuol dire come
lo batto questo ad e andate a demo
battere all ondate tipo e tipo la grid
minchia che mostrano va ad ondate quindi
e poi e poi lo sconfitto automaticamente
o devo battere pure lui mi chiedi e
bruttissimo cioè difficile
madonna
no ragazzi assurdo questo va presa i
nemici e bellissima sta roba è veramente
figo il mio dominion quale nuovo raga
non c'era prima è fighissimo ti frizza
proprio il nemico e quando lo colpisci
farfa questa cosa
bellissimo e anche sarà utile perché fa
danno
non ho
merda
l'hack è male per doverlo il cuore
sicuro
perdo sicuro al cuore
merda che botta 6 l'ho perso
5 nonno questo che poi debba battere
anche lui perché già è difficile così di
figuriamoci
penso che poi sia morto perché proprio
già difficile questa 6 su 6
e sto avendo già una difficoltà il
suprema
l'hack è male porca put anza
è morto minchia raga che casino mi ha
dato un oggetto di merda due ore questo
schifo dai allora raga questa non ce
l'ho
non so cos'è non c'è neanche nella
nell'app
queens è fortissimo praticamente ogni
tot che ammazzi gente ti spa una un
minion vediamo
eccolo lì veniva stato mio è veramente
forte starò a semi spa ex guardanti mi
chiamo suonato mariah pazzesco
è veramente assurdo non è mamma vero
teramano nel mamma
che cazzo devo fare qua
aiuto a lanciare ste mondo ok
però non li faccio danno se no stavo con
le bombe merda
a [ __ ] meno male che aprissi piva
schivato tutto ci sono qui sono dei boss
che di puoi fare danno solo con le cose
che trovi in giro a li togli la corazza
pulita dal normale che perché prego
meno male ci sono i minion guarda mi
fanno danno pazzesco quello è all stat
up ma tutte le stata platel e sciabola è
un casino davvero chi lo prendo
sono stata upson star trek ho fatto più
danno mi muovo lentissimo però molto più
danno boh secondo me non è male
satana vediamo cosa c'è
che non
mi ricordo cosa sono
ma mi dicono cosa fanno regalo uno ti fa
volare che questo
l'altro mi cosa fa di tipo dei mash up
per non mi ricordo quanto vediamo fa
questo ragazzo porca [ __ ] vediamo se
funziona non so se serve però io lo
faccio lo uso
aspetta fa questa cosa guardate i miei
cuori
tutti ti toglie tutti i quali ma ti da
tutti i cuori neri e che aumenta
il danno che a mente un po la speed
diciamo che è abbastanza utile per come
stavo messo adesso però comunque il
fatto di non avere più con i normali
pesa no man mano che palle
le manone di mamma che mi schiacciano
dei
chi cacchio al minion sto male ma lei
che cattivi disastro è veramente forte
però sono tutti i minion che non sparano
da soli e quindi non posso usare ancora
la leaf che sarebbe questo ancora non
posso se ne trova uno che spara da solo
è finita completamente una roba positiva
io posso avere questa su di sfiga
perenne ma posso apro questo che merda
mi ricordo cosa fa ah ok ok praticamente
sparito rica mente spara da solo se sta
vicino ai nemici spara da solo con
joinet ho trovato è praticamente fuori a
vedere minion ho sbloccato la la con
gioia di che questa questo è questa
evoluzione quindi questo dovrebbe stare
da sola e vediamo se funziona test
chiesto fermo
sono fermo quindi non mi può fare danno
a nessuno e lui fa danno a tutti hai
visto è fortissima del iv iii prima che
adesso se non mi avvicino quello non lo
fa nessuno fuori ok ma esse possono
scegliere anni non sono uscite como
bene sono messo abbastanza bene ragazzi
mamma fermate
fai tu io non faccio niente vedere che
succede
al proprio lui
bene è stata è stata vasaio sono molto
affaticato allora e non so se devo
andare di sopra o di sotto per il
semplice fatto che non so che con non so
i boss nuovi cosa sono
non so quali sono i quali siano i boss
nuovi quindi non so se andare sopra
sotto dettati non lo so vado sopra di
sopra
ok let's go
va bene perché io non ho ben capito se
effettivamente tutti i nuovi boss li
trovi solo nelle porte vicine oppure se
ti trovi anche cosa qua
sono cioè tutto c'è anche una
hanno messo liquido amniotico nell'uomo
va bene per rendere tutto un po più
veritiero va bene ho capito è un po
strana come cosa però vabbè ci sta ha
senso scientificamente
tutto si muove come se fossimo
ancora nella placenta nice ragazzi e sto
bene sto sbattendo del fatto che posso
stare fermo perché se non è tutto un
gameplay monotono però potreste stare
fermo ad ogni istanza sostanzialmente
chissenefrega sarebbero che dura 80 anni
però almeno arrivo alla fine questo
sicuro e comunque change my mind ma
l'uomo a parte quando mi colpiscono che
mi levano un andamento è molto più
semplice del tutte le stanze che nuove
nel dlc nuovo quando avrò proprio un
cuore rimango proprio fermo della serie
non mi deve succedere niente
ok vediamo cotoniero note plot è
orribile del raw terribile ragazzi sono
sempre odiato anche perché li devo
rimanere dietro però mi fa danno
veramente è uno di quelli che oggi di
più perché fa danno sempre ok ora
logica vorrebbe che io stessi fermo ogni
volta che succede qualcosa perché
sto morendo sostanzialmente meno che non
uso la riga because he fa eterna life
non quando muoio posso risposto la
possibilità di risparmiare non è male
non è male aprendo questo vado sotto
però dei turisti afferma ogni stanza
sostanzialmente per essere sicuri non
prender danno che sono muoio però vabbè
è un po e un po tu max non ho voglia di
stare ferme massimo muoio ragazzi cazzi
cioè stare fermi per non prenderla né
per quella euro in parte in poi adesso
lo sapevo
eternal no non ha funzionato scolare di
carpi peccato comunque era veramente una
bella ram peccato che hanno buttata così
signori spero che vi sia piaciuto questa
di panico baisakhi oggi consentono a me
piace anche ai social gomitata
descrizione so se ci si chiede allora
seguito della ragazza
[Musica]